hey it's Teddy swims check me out on the
bootleg K podcast hey before we get into
the interview we want to give a shout
out to our family over at Imperial
extraction they're bringing you today's
episode um and check this out if you
want a free 2 G thca loaded pre-roll yes
that's right you can get one of these
for free you don't have to buy anything
all you got to do is go to Imperial
extraction. comom use the promo code
bootleg and they're going to send you
one of these for free look premium glass
tip one more time Imperial extraction.
comom promo code bootleg you're going to
get a free 2 G THC Diamond loaded
pre-roll that's 1 and 12 gram of that
premium top shell flour and a half a
gram of THC diamonds loaded up to your
door for free just pay shipping let's
get into the
interview bootle cab podcast bootle cab
show we got a special guest in here I've
been a fan of this guy for I don't know
three or four years now ever since I
discovered you on the internet Teddy
swims hey thanks for having me bro I'm
so stoked to be here dude I watch this
podcast like always like man I want to
get on this so bad so look at this it's
do we made happen at your manifesting
life you know come on great the first
time I met you I was very very [__]
hammered at the uh it was at jelly roll
had a show out here at the trador I
think yeah sure did man what an angel
and I was blasted what an absolute Angel
yeah we we had a good night we drank a
lot yeah we freaking did amongst others
I remember jelly had gotten like right
after we was upstairs in the little like
I don't know I guess the bar area and he
had just he was just sitting back you
know like just sitting back in the booth
and they just kept bringing trays full
of like 30 he's like what 30 more
Tequilas please 30 more casamigos and I
was like a [__] night man hey it's
been dope to see uh just your come up
dude I've been um you know I use
your layout cuz I I always talk to
aspiring singers and songwriters right
and I always use you as an example to
like how to use the internet in your
favor because if you're super talented
like you have the voice of an Angel
right well thank you I found you I think
it was I think it was the Mario cover
all right yeah like 2019 yeah yeah and
um ever since then I subscribed to the
YouTube channel and I always will show
people like yo there's this guy Teddy
swims like he's doing like covers but
he's doing them like with like care with
like high production value and like you
know it it's dope that you know that was
kind of like would you say that those
covers were kind of your way in to kind
of becoming discovered on a big
absolutely man we really really
originally didn't intend on doing them
was just like so June 25th of 2019 was
the first one we did and I wanted to
just kind of pay homage to Michael
Jackson because it was 10 years after he
died and we just woke up and it was just
kind of going crazy so we were like I
mean I think I think the first year that
first day after we posted it we woke up
with like 10,000 views you know and and
now that such like seems like such a
middle school number if I get like not
if I don't get a million on something
now I'm like oh [__] kill me I suck
you know but but that 10,000 we woke up
to bro we were like holy [__] guys we
got [__] 10,000 views W what the [__]
you know and it it was it was so cool
man and uh and so since then we like I
guess this is working I me we just kept
going and kept doing more covers and and
started you know and that's kind of what
Teddy swims just kind of became its own
thing because um we were we're were
banned forever you know and then it was
just that that just kind of went off and
we're just I guess we're just shifting
gears and me and all my buds and you
know just just kept doing it at what
point in time were you like cuz I know
there had to be a point in time where
every major label was coming at you like
like almost like you're LeBron James
like a free agent orud it it was quite
it was quite neat too cuz uh so I I once
once those like covers started really
kind of going off and and that that
Mario cover was really one that was
first starting to go and uh and Shai
Twain Still The One cover really did a
lot for us and but after that first one
I was talking to my buddies at the time
and cuz we were all in band and stuff I
was still in a metal band and and still
playing and uh and and we we would have
like the same guys that would you know
kind of record us man my good friend Le
Rouse and and uh My Buddy Aaron and Joel
who like filmed filmed the videos and so
at one point we were just kind of he did
a great job yeah we had we had we had
like I had this idea was like look man I
think I think if we I think we just all
put our heads together like let's just
like just do this do covers like weekly
let's just get together write songs for
this project that way when we get ready
to you know get signed whatever it is
that we're going to do I just asked my
friends to give me like 6 months of
their time and I said just 6 months and
we're man so we all moved into this
house together in Snellville Georgia and
it was like a five-bedroom house and we
like put plyboard walls up and made two
bedrooms out I mean we ended up making
this thing like a nine-bedroom it was
five but it was really n yeah it was
like nine bedroom house man we had like
15 I think 12 of us were living there
and like 15 of us were there every day
it was a [__] and this is where you
guys were recording and yeah it was like
[__] tadea over there man you know
what I'm saying and we we so we we had
like we had built like two studios in it
and then you know we had our like we had
our uh our garage was was where we like
could distribute our own merch too and
my brother would come over there and
distribute our merch and it was the
merch Factory in the garage yes it more
like do two studios in there a bunch of
rooms and I just figured like I was like
well we can film we can record we can
write we can sing we can make all this
stuff ourselves we can we can do all of
it we can take the pictures we can
distribute the merch so I was like it
just 6 months let's all put our heads
together on this and if it if if it
works out then like we're all going to
be straight because we we don't need
anybody you know and um sure enough we
June 25th of 2019 was the first cover we
did and in December 24th of 2019 uh
signed a Warner Records and put all my
best buds on salary and it was a day
less than six months which is [__]
wild out like just speaking things into
existence and and you put all the homies
who were there with you on the team [__]
they're still they're still [__] same
van and still same guys and and now
we're actually making pretty damn good
money man so everybody's everybody's
doing good and uh aot lots of them about
to move out here too man and just keep
and they've all had like writing cuts on
records with me and producing cuts and
you know we just we keep we keep going
together man no it's been dope to see
man um so you say you're were in a metal
band around the time you did the first
cover yeah sure was man I was I was in
my whole life I spent a lot of those uh
you can still find some of the stuff
it's called Uh this band's called AIS a
e r i s and you can find it what kind of
metal are we talking here it was like
kind of a more post metal core kind of
there was singing there some Screaming a
little more some some kind of active
Rock situation little post hardcore
little metal core kind of little bit of
everything in it you know just it it it
was all right it was pretty good there's
some there's some decency in it yeah so
all that stuff still out there for
everybody Che yeah sure is man it's
crazy cuz like your like your music now
I feel like is you know there's a void
and I feel like uh our friend jelly
rolls feel in that void just good
songwriting good like I'm talking about
even on the pop side because now when I
listen to Kiss FM or even you know
certain rhythmic stations you'll hear
your single and it's just good music
from the soul and I feel like that is
like a there's a void of that in our
current music landscape yeah I think so
too I think there's a I think I think I
I'm I'm really happy that it was that
song too cuz I think I I I have this
thing where I always want to blend to
whatever I think something needs to
sound like or or like you don't want to
get on a trend of something
find that the that get on trends that
out are just always like a flash in
thean or have like one big song you know
and and I think the ones that are real
things that really stick around are real
disruptors you know and I hope that um I
I like I like what's what's great about
lose control being my big first single
that's that's kind of broken into the
market taken off yeah it's it's uh it's
it leaves me with so much room to go so
many wherever you want to go from it's
it's it's got the soul it's got some
country elements some mtown elements
some damn rock and roll elements yeah
it's got everything in it and and I'm
glad to know that it's working and it's
working on different Avenues you know
it's working on rhythmic radios and and
pop radio you got R&B remix out there
you got the going crazy it's it's great
to see that it's working and uh and it
gives me just absolute room to go
wherever the hell I want from here I
think and and not be too left field you
know talk about uh influences coming up
in bands and [__] like what were some of
your band influences like like give me
your like three or four greatest bands
of all time bands okay let's go bands
first yeah of all time I see so as far
as like influence goes I'd have to say
like so there's a band called uh
acceptance when I was like in like sixth
grade uh like first band I ever like
really got into acceptance like changed
my life I remember playing like you
remember like NFL Street 2 when that
came out like NFL Street was that the
one with Ricky Williams on the cover
they had they had like exhibit was in it
uh but everybody it was dude it was all
the street games are so fire so sick man
they so sick I mean the uh the I I
recently played sorry to get off track
here but I recently played the NBA
streets and the the old school one yeah
the camera it's like side angle so you
kind of don't have really depth
perception so you're just like kind of
going right by the goal it doesn't hold
up as well as you remember no but NBA
Street NFL Street and the what was the
skate games the uh skate the skate that
was all my sh yeah we got to bring all
that [__] the uh the the oh man and the
uh de Jam vendettas bro come on who
would you be during like dude man red
man every time red man was my hero dude
well how high is like one of my favorite
movies of all time with him and meth
yeah man that's like one of the best
movies of all time it's so funny like
that that game existed I had that game
and then there was this wuang game on
PlayStation it was a fighting game where
you could pick like all nine members of
wuang and then you'd fight like evil
monks and [__] that's so sick but yeah
Vendetta was that [__] for sure man well
but anyway fans so there was there was a
song on to uh on on uh on NFL Street too
and it was this song called into to far
by acceptance and I was like I just fell
in love with it and I went and found
this album foms and it just like changed
my life it's one of the first ones I
ever listened to I like God I want this
is like I was all they were all over my
MySpace like everything like all all
songs all their whole that whole album
is all over my MySpace so I like
acceptance is up there for me um Cirus
survive man Anthony Green one of the
greatest of all times I think as far as
a van goes I was so I was so invested in
Circus of VI still am man I mean he's
he's in LS Dunes now just he's just one
of the greatest I think um chotos man
also oh 2007 like Warp Tour you know
just two chotos was incredible man I
Warp Tour was an ER God it was so that
was one of the first shows I ever went
to man and uh I mean I'll have to I
obviously have to throw Van Halen in
there too as bands go because come on uh
uh Lincoln Park man on Chester man yeah
come on man M Nota just came out on
stage at um some radio show I was like
oh [__] I think he came on stage with
somebody he they they've changed my life
man I got those first two albums man
were like my childhood dude Hybrid
Theory is one of the first ones I got
that uh I got my one of my first like
Christmas where I got um got CDs and you
remember when they used to be wrapped
and you just knew your parents got you
those yeah cuz it was a stpe of a CD it
dude but I had gotten I had gotten
Hybrid Theory um U no pads no helmets
just balls but Simple Plan and uh there
was there was like a three CD set of
switch foot it was like Legend of chin
and I forget the other two uh Records on
it but it's like three CDs all them you
knew you were getting CDs for Christmas
and DVDs or games you'd be like is this
a movie or a game yeah yeah that that
was that was the catchy far yeah did you
get a DVD or or video game I hope it's a
game I hope it's not a [__] movie I
don't I don't want to I don't want a
copy of Click you know what I mean I
don't need clerks I'm fine I you know no
that's dope man yeah know Lincoln Park I
got to see them uh I went as a kid to
the Hybrid Theory tour oh so jealous and
they had a this there's this rapper
named MC Supernatural I don't know if
you ever heard of him but supernat is
like the
freestyle
God so at the time he would do this [__]
where he would I would see him on these
like smaller hip-hop shows for like
dilated people's of Jurassic 5 and [__]
um and he would do this thing where he
would spin around and come as like and
impersonate another rapper so he'd like
spin around and be rapping like exhibit
and then he'd spin around he'd be
rapping sick and he's the first person I
ever saw like take someone's ID from the
crowd and wrap their name and their
birthplace and so they had him open the
um Lincoln Park tour and it was so crazy
but cuz I never seen somebody combine
like hardcore real hip-hop [__] and like
rock [__] in that way and without it
being corny yeah they they were dude cuz
there were some corny the the rap rock
era it got corny it got a little corny
you know and I think a lot of that has
to do with Joe Han too man cuz he that
just did Lincoln Park always had that
that DJ you know they had the DJ and
they had like and they had the roots too
like styles of Beyond and [__] yeah
exactly they they're just real real
hip-hop fans I think entirely you know
and I think like I I got a chance to
work with them a couple times and just
kind of go over to mics and and
experiment with them and play and it was
so cool because I've never seen I've
never seen actually like Joe still he
like still has like so when they're
sampling stuff it's not like they're
going to splice like everyone else
everyone's he's really he's really
pulling out records and and finding
moments in there and sampling them real
time still as they're like writing and
I'm like dude it was so neat to see cuz
I've never seen that just somebody
sample into recording that's how they
actually do it as opposed to like on a
website download an MP3 and put it it's
so easy for us now which thank God I
would I like that about it I would be
[__] lost if it was up to me if you
like man if I got to go sit in this
great just go like high hat 13 30 BPM
and
just oh that one you know that's so sick
to do that now I'm like I wouldn't
change it for the world but it was cool
to see that like he's still he's still
dedicated to you know like and doing DJ
just like really doing like when people
are really using records still it's so
[__] it's got to be cool like for you
like have you realized that you cuz you
know I always say we grew up having a
dream and then when we accompl
accomplish the dream like if somebody
were to tell probably you 10 years ago
that you'd have a million views on
YouTube you'd be like oh [__] [__]
right we're on but like I feel like when
we hit those dreams like we don't even
like take time to like really appreciate
it you it's always about what's next
yeah I try I try to I try to now like
I'm trying to get to that point but you
know you're so in it that you like sit
in a room with Mike shenoda and like the
Lincoln Park guys I'm like freaking out
oh man yeah that was definitely one of
those times where we we we're talking
about things and I was just like look
guys like I'm stoked that we're friends
but just don't ever forget that I'm
going to be more of a fan than I'll ever
be your friend like I I love you so much
you know like I'm I'm just here to like
soak in sponge in all the little stories
like tell me [__] everything I know
everything you know cuz they're D and
they it's just like man also recording
vocals with Mike Shoto is like such a uh
he's such a he's such a [__] genius
when it comes to that because he'll
he'll do this thing to which I'm like
such a chameleon cuz I grew up on such
different type of music so if we're
doing something Rock I just instantly
kind of find myself gearing my voice
towards this particular sound or like if
we're doing like some mot toown I kind
of gear my voice towards like and I kind
of play a character a lot you know and
he kind of broke me down and was like
okay okay okay let's just try this take
again and we could be the most [__]
heaviest part of the song and he's like
but don't give me such rock and roll
Teddy give me like give me m give me
like yeah try that one out see what that
character sounds like okay is there in
between of those two that you can kind
of do okay so why don't you give me like
your like why don't you give you more
like indie rock Voice or why don't you
give me more this kind of voice why
don't try some [__] weird give me
musical theater Ted right here like
you're or offer just give me some offro
you know and he's and we'll just he'll
kind of like carve it I'll just like
damn I never thought those things would
go together you know cuz my brain just
goes like like you know and I don't I
don't think to tra change my voice to
not fit What It Is Well you have the
ability to do so much like if you
dropped the country album tomorrow
nobody would take T like that's that's
what I that's what I if you did a R&B
album that's the plan man I hope to I
hope to be able to just kind of I always
I always wanted to say that like uh I
will forever be um I I could be second
best at anything for sure and and that's
enough like I can I can cuz you couldn't
put this person in a you couldn't you
know like Chris Brown couldn't put out a
country record I mean he could I'm sure
he crush it but he does his thing you
know but people would be like really
George Strait wouldn't put out a you
know like you couldn't put him an RB
record I mean you could I'm sure you
could but they would do their thing you
know and so I always like gave myself
this like I I will be second best at
every one of these things don't you
worry I think I can I can guarantee you
I'll be second best at all of them hey
want to give a shout out to our family
at King pal baby want to shout out to
King pal man they've been holding us
down for a minute now and um I feel like
my life kind of changed once I started
smoking out of King Palms because it's
so smooth man it's organic there's no
tobacco no nicotine it's a natural Leaf
uh and the best part about these King
Pals they come in so many flavors this
is the latest flavor that I'm on right
now it's the pink lemonade now it's dope
it's a turpine infused tip you get to
stuff your flour in it light it up you
squeeze that tip and you get hit with a
burst of flavor and it is SCH smacking
all right so let me tell you about King
pom we hooked up to hook you up if you
go to King pom.com right now you can
order anything from the website if you
want a box of these if you want a
grinder if you want an ashtray if you
want some of these you know what I mean
whatever you need some of that Lemon
Haze you know I know the holidays just
passed but you like that pumpkin cream
pie they got that too all right whatever
you need it's half off half off 50% off
when you go to King pom.com and use the
promo code bootleg 50% off not to
mention if you're in town you're driving
around wherever you're at I don't care
where you're from where you're watching
this from go to the 7-Eleven they got
King pom go to your local smoke shop
they got King pom the industry leader of
natural tobacco nicotine-free smoking
experience and trust me when I say you
got to [__] with them bootleg is the
promo code at King pom.com get half off
also want to give a shout out to odd
Soxs can we get some odd
socks look at all these [__] Odd
Socks we got here oh my
God first of all the modellos are hidden
all right so look if y'all don't know
man odd Sox just celebrated uh their 10
year anniversary I was out in Tampa with
them they're are family they're are are
just our dogs for real for real and um
they are the most comfortable socks in
the
world Listen the most comfortable socks
in the world if you guys ever see me
anywhere I'll always have these on or
the white version of the basics to me
these are like walking on clouds and if
you're into I don't know
Monopoly you know I don't know maybe you
are you're a [__] a Pez guy who the
[__] a p guy uh SpongeBob maybe you're
an alcoholic maybe you like beer so much
so I'm first of all I love these Modello
socks they're fly as [__] all right uh I
don't know which ones I like more Corona
Modello I think I'm GNA go with the
modello socks and I think I like Medela
more than Corona um bubbalicious man um
how about the Power Rangers whatever
you're into they got it I mean look WWE
cocacola uh Doritos uh I mean Godfather
they got all the licenses all right odd
Soxs is changing the game the most
comfortable socks in the world I want
you to try out some odd Soxs save 20%
right now don't forget they got the
underwear too save 20% right now when
you go to oddsocks official.com and use
the promo code
bootleg and uh we want to say shout out
to them and congrats to their 10y year
anniversary our partners our family at
odd Soxs oh these are GI Joe draws I'mma
take these home let's get back to the
interview did you listen to a lot of
hip-hop at alls yeah absolutely man gr
up in Georgia I'm sure yeah dude but
that's I think that's what it was just
just the Melting Pot of of culture
culture itself man we had all the best
country music we had all the best soul
music we had the best hip-hop music
everything all best rock music
everything came from Georgia man and I'm
I'm so lucky and fortunate to be raised
in in in that just culture and Melting
Pot and and see so many different
Avenues and sides of of of American
culture you know we just had turbo uh
who's a producer for gunana he had he
did drip too hard which is Diamond but I
just interviewed him before you came
here and I told him that you were coming
he got super he's like yo connect us no
way turbo you probably you know his you
know his you know his producer T but
he's huge well please I was like oh yeah
we got Teddy swims he's like Teddy swis
he's hard I would I would be I would be
absolutely honored man what a what a
gangster man that guy's [__] yeah
he's he's him dude I would love I would
be I'd be honored uh when growing up in
the South were you a college football
guy absolutely man like are you a
bulldog guy you [__] know it's a good
day to be a dog I mean we we didn't make
it I think I think we got I think we got
[__] out of getting the national
championship and getting our three peat
but it's whatever but it's just so crazy
how it's like it's really like a
religion in the South it is man I I love
it too man I got to go to I got to go to
the NA national championship last year
out here in La you know and it was like
for the absolute spanking we put on them
and it was just dude I've never been so
[__] hammered in my life it was a
time of my life dude just screaming man
and um not too long ago I think like a
couple years ago now we we had closed
out our tour in uh Georgia Theater in
Athens and we end up becoming good
friends with this guy Josh Brooks he's
an athletic director there and he let me
and my my tour manager my best bud
Curtis uh kind of see the whole like the
whole the whole athletic department you
know and it was dude it was nuts man
there's like he's like it's like the
best [__] hundred million dollars can
buy you know what I mean it's like it's
crazy in there dude I got to uh I met I
met Kirby Smart right the coach and I
never been like Star Struck by anyone
before you know like cuz you would think
it'd be like somebody that I look up to
like that that would really leave me
like but it was it was the football
coach for me that like really he was
just like hey son how you doing man and
I was like I was like yeah hi yeah he's
like so you say you're playing at
Georgia Theater I was like yes sir yes
sir I've seen a lot of cool bands there
man said yes sir thank you sir I'm so sh
I couldn't figure out what the [__] to
say to KY smart and I'm like I know L of
was like I walked away from that like
what the [__] why was I so struck by
that but I I go through the same [__]
like I'll meet like cuz I think cuz I'm
in the field like if I meet a musician
or a rapper or artist like it's cool to
meet him but i' I've met everybody you
know so it's like but if I meet like an
actor or like a wrestler yeah that's
that's yeah [__] exactly man I'm like so
excited to meet like like I met Jimmy
Hart Hulk Hogan's manager from the 80s
at a restaurant once and I was just like
oh I got I I gotta go bother him while
he's eating like I'm not that guy but
I'm going to walk up to Jimmy Hart the
mouth of the South and just be like hey
I know you're eating but like before you
leave can I get a picture and he was
like of course young man and I was like
well thank you man yeah that that but I
don't care like like if it was like you
know but I'm just you know like if I
ever met Larry David I'd be besides
myself you know yeah [__] Dwayne The
Rock Johnson walks here right now pass
out dude I'd absolutely freak out if he
just yeah man Will Smith walked in here
right now out dude I just be like go or
Dave Chappelle Chappelle I got actually
got to smoke weed that's number one for
me man God Martin Lawrence man that's
number one you see Chappelle's new
standup is so good he's the best man go
man he is the greatest man I got I got a
tattoo of him right here on my thigh too
you have a Chappelle tattoo he's right
here manit him and uh Martin Lawrence
playing Jerome oh I love it yeah yeah
man he's right here that's my favorite
show of all time man Martin is Martin is
Martin's like my my Goto bedtime show
like every day you can always throw
Martin on it's the best show ever man me
and my pops used to watch that and he's
just just the funniest man funniest this
greatest show I think of all time I
really I will give I will give Martin
greatest show of all time I always say
like uh when I talk about Martin it's
either like as a as a kid it was like
Martin or fresh prince different shows
but still very both like integral parts
of my childhood and I mean man Martin
was funnier obviously I but you get like
some real life lessons yeah you did you
did man you really did man and and it's
so it's so good I I just recently
listened that the uh I've listened to
the Will Smith book you know will and
you know it's and it's uh it's quite
funny cuz he's talking about he's
talking about how in the first and I
didn't even notice until I went back and
watch some of him again that he was like
you could see him like clearly mouthing
everybody else's lines and I I didn't I
didn't know until he was like sharing
that story and I went back and watched
him and you could just see him
like know everybody's lines crazy man
work yeah Mar's up there what's your
favorite Chappelle Show skit um man I I
I probably have to say I probably it to
me it might be that Prince episode you
know Charlie Murphy man rest in peace
also dude that was a good one and I just
rewatched me and my wife just watched
the the standup special and I was like
all right I got to put Chappelle Show on
cuz to me the the most flagrant
hilarious skit ever put on television is
Clayton Bigsby yeah about dude I I was
about to say clayon makes face dude
black racist yeah yeah black racist yeah
he's just blind and he doesn't he's he's
like come on Clayton we want to see your
face we want to see your face he said
you want to see my face and he takes it
off and his head explodes everywhere
it's something it's something that like
it's something that only he could get
away with you know what I mean like he's
he's just he's the best at that man and
you can't B an eye it man he just pushed
the boundaries man always does yeah and
then Tyrone Bam's doing um Fear Factor I
don't know he said I don't know if you
know this J Rogan but I smoke
rocks and he walks right across the hot
Stones like yeah no Chappelle man he is
the greatest of all time man I feel like
the best comedies like as a kid like not
the best but some of the best like that
didn't last long enough and The
Boondocks I don't know if you ever
watched The Boondocks love yeah we we we
missed out on we got two great seasons
of it the third season wasn't written by
the OG's so it wasn't as great but the
first two seasons oh like if I could see
The Boondocks do like a croon rock
blueface episode in
2024 it'd be it'd be incredible they
could they they has to do for a comeback
everything comes back right um dude one
one one guy I've been like watching a
lot uh there's this guy Shane Gillis
listen to him god dude listen Shane
Gillis right now is the greatest stand
up alive I think I think I think I dude
I think I think he's like that beautiful
dogs and I mean everything he does from
podcast I'm a comedian geek yeah me too
me and my boy James my co-host we talk
about this all the time and we're like
yo right now yeah Shane nobody can [__]
with Shane dude I I've watched that
beautiful dogs like seven times and I
can't quit crying like I you know what I
like about what he like what Shane
Gillis does is so good is like it
doesn't matter what side of the aisle
you're on like politically he he's
you're you're laughing yeah he yeah he's
he just so his Trump impersonation is
god dude when I would have cried yeah
when he did that
joke did you see the clip where
Chappelle brought him on stage to do the
yeah he's like he's like Joe Biden's the
only President you can you can punch
assassinate all you [__] and he's
dead do I was [__] you have you
messing no I I I I messaged him like you
know a couple times I I message him one
time to say like hey man you're the
greatest alive right now you know and
then then you know we exchang that Merry
Christmas too I was like bro we got to
hang one day man you know so we've
talked a couple times on Instagram but
I'm like that's a dude I would just
absolutely love to just
talk to
and smash some Bud Lights smoke some
cigarettes let
go yeah he's a he's a [__] cool dude
no he's the goat man um I actually got
to I was near Shane Gillis I was in
Austin my friend's a rapper named Freddy
Gibbs he went on Rogan and I went with
him and I was like I saw Joe Rogan and
met him at his place super cool spot I
bet uh later on that night we go to a
comedy show everybody's there but I go
up to Joe Rogan and I'm like hey man I
started eating shrooms cuz your podcast
and so I pulled out some shrooms and I
was like would you take a micro do with
me and he was like I got to plan that
[__] out buddy and I was like it's okay
I'll have I'll have two so I was off of
[__] shrooms and I also had an edible
and I was drinking dude and I had one of
the most fried yeah bugged out tweaked
out nights of my life in Texas it was
just that's the place to go do it though
you know just bunch of beautiful
landscape just everything flat have you
ever had like a terrible trip no
actually man I I've had I've had some
moments you know but I feel like they
always led to like real profound like
I've had I've had like I've had of a
better man I've had a couple where I
just like just solved and I was like God
this is perfect this is every it's
always taught me something really good I
think the closest thing I ever had to
one that was weird so uh my best friend
move uh Jamal Bridges man uh he we we
had went for his 21st birthday so his
dad like lived in Vegas and and we we we
going to bring a bunch of shrooms and
we're like [__] we didn't figure out how
we were going to fly with these can't
just fly with out some mushrooms you
know but we were we were [__] so we
decided we decided just take a gigantic
just eighth a mouthful man and got an
eighth of it a piece and um oh [__] and
when dude dude it was the worst
situation of my life I mean the flight
was great cuz it was like from from like
daytime to night time East Coast from
Atlanta to West Coast and I saw like the
sun setting but we were also flying
spirit so I might have been helpful you
know what it might have been helpful cuz
it was nothing to watch you know so I
know so I was just looking out the
window for 5 hours like like and you're
like this there's no room but getting on
the flight like the flight was
absolutely breathtaking you know and but
go like it was Saturday night at Atlanta
Airport the busiest airport ever and I'm
[__] tripping face on mushrooms going
through TSA and that was like that was
the worst thing that has ever happened
to me that was like I was that was like
I don't know how I'm going to get
through it I just felt like I was like
walking with my backpack like a [__]
robot I've been there and everybody was
just like I thought I thought everyone
star TSA hammered on anything is rough
just buy take your [__] shoes off
you're
like yeah thank God for free cheick
nowadays not that I'm doing mushrooms at
the airport anymore but why would you do
that if I was right now in my life it
would be the prime timee check would be
the time or or you know when go to like
a like a private jet or something yeah
exactly right now is a prime time to go
through DS you land in Vegas and you're
just primed up for Vegas as soon as yeah
man and we we we spent like 5 days for
his 21st birthday and you know we all
just young kids and [__] having the
time of our life it was magical Vegas is
fun you g yeah but it's like two or
three days max for me I I used live five
was just [__] EXA you guys end up at
uh the Spearmint Rhino at all no we did
not we that was just a great St I went I
went I saved up like $500 and I went and
I just quarter slotted it and I left
with like 600 bucks after five days of
kind of eating fuckingn so I was like
yeah baby you're up 100 bucks after a
week yeah I was like that's pretty good
that was pretty solid so now I just
stick to the ding-dings baby you know
just gambling is a it can get bad like
yeah I I I I can't get the I can't get
the bug for it man cuz I just like I
don't have the sports gambling you'll
get the bug for yeah I but see I see one
thing I look about sports gambling I was
talking to my buddy about this and I
make like little ass bets like maybe
like $5 on like a six game parlay you
know like if it hits you win three bucks
yeah you know and it's it's it's not
[__] money but also it like it's like it
makes the games not only more
interesting and usually five bucks for
like a couple days of dopamine Rush it's
like way cheaper than what I'd pay for
dopamine rushes any other time you know
what I mean usually dopamine cost you
like a hundred bucks and you get an hour
with your friend and then you're laying
in bed like you need more [__] godamn
it I can't sleep and then you're just
trying to jerk off until you can pass
out and that's not happening either
it's true sometimes that's what I try to
tell my wife sometimes I'm like honey
sometimes you just got to rub one out to
get to bed it has nothing to do with you
it has to do with me yeah then you're
[__] laying there till 6:00 a.m. like
you [__] liar everybody if they
[__] knew what you you know you just
beating yourself up cuz all that
dopamine's gone your bra you're going
beat yourself off yeah beating yourself
up and beating yourself off guy is
[__] that guy's just [__] laying
there like come on man come on man do
something for me baby I got to go to
sleep there's nothing like trying to go
to sleep on shrooms though CU then you
close your eyes and you're like [__]
have you ever have you ever like [__]
boned anybody on
mushrooms I I always think about it you
know like or I always think like damn
should have tried jerking off that could
have been cool you know and I just never
that's just the last thing on my mind
when I'm when I'm in the middle of a
trip I don't I'm not like let's [__]
go jerk off real quick I just don't
think and and just being alone jerking
on tripping BS is a I've probably only
jerked off on shrooms like twice was it
tight it wasn't bad okay I know if it
was going to be like sick you know I
just full screen oh [__] yeah headphones
on VR set Oculus on oh the you know
what's crazy is I haven't tried that but
I have an Oculus oh yeah he time to run
that baby yo the Oculus porn while on
shrooms take a couple more tops and see
what happens to you oh [__] text me and
let me know wash your hands first though
you know what I'm saying
you ever have post hey hey Teddy have
you ever had post nut Clarity yeah all
the time man where you're like you got
like 13 tabs going on the Hub God and
you're like you disgusting disra you
bust you look down and you're like a
[__] God all these potential [__]
jerks you had like yeah God I can't even
get to all the tabs you know I know I I
try I try my best to just be like you
know these days I'm like man it's it's
it's it's so awful for your brain to
know that we just have something new all
the time you know just have something
like whatever we want whatever ticks our
little button is like and is so negative
thumnails you got find the thumbnail it
can't be good for you it's terrible for
you oh it's horrible especially if
you're trying to be in love with someone
you know it's probably bad so I try to I
try to now I mean now currently I'm
single so it's you know [__] it I can
look at whatever I want you know but I
want to follow I'm I'm I'm at a spot
where I'm longing for companion ship and
I like you know and I have a hopeful so
I'm trying to be like better about just
jerking off six
what you can do is you could sleep on
your hand right and then you wake up and
it's dead and then you get your your
your arms asleep and you give yourself a
stranger The Stranger yeah yeah the
left-handed Str for me it's the
right-handed stranger that's what they
do in jail they give themselves
strangers that's a good idea and more
than one way in more than one way in
more than one so hey let's stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our folks at my bookie damn it all right
look NFL playoffs are going down Super
Bowl's on the way go to my bookie right
now and let's get in on the action not
not to mention right now is the time to
sign up all right if you sign up with
the promo code bootleg mybookie.ag head
over there right now you're going to get
your um first deposit bonus up to
$1,000 all right that means you put in
that promo code you put in your money
they're going to match it they're going
to get you right up to
$1,000 um and uh I don't care what
you're into same game parlays uh I don't
care if you want to get down with the uh
uh over unders you know what I'm saying
some of the prop bets whatever it is my
bookie is going to get you situated all
right so go to
mybookie.ag get in on this action all
right I just hit a crazy they got this
thing where you could put three teams on
a teaser and they give you plus 13 if
it's a three- leg teaser woo look do
that tomorrow do that next weekend on
these NFL games trust me you know what
you're doing you should be able to hit
that all right pretty good odds on it
too all right so go to mybookie.ag sign
up with the pr code bootleg and get that
first deposit bonus up to $1,000 right
now also want to give a shout out to our
folks at bluechew listen man it's
getting cold outside it's cold as hell
outside out here in LA right now you see
me I got the jacket on it's cold it's
cuffing season all right if you got a
rectile dysfunction uh if you're dealing
with stress at work if your dick ain't
[__] it's all good blue Cho got you
all right let me tell you about blue Chu
a lot of people always are asking me
does blue Chu work yes it works like a
charm all right
go to
blue.com use the promo code bootleg when
you sign up and they're going to show
you that it works cuz they're going to
send you a month for free that's right a
month supply of bluechew for free all
you got to do is pay $5 shipping all
right blue.com use the promo code
bootleg same active ingredient as Viagra
and Calis but it comes in a chewable
form and it's delivered right to your
door in a very discreet packaging you
don't have to go to the doctors anymore
to talk about why you're dicks you know
underperforming you know and look I'm
going be honest the blue Chu is kind of
like you know when Barry Bonds hit 70
home runs hey look bro if you want to
impress abroad get you a blue you go all
night bro your dick ain't never been
harder blu.com promo code bootleg get a
free month supply right now all right
all you got to do is pay shipping let's
get back to the interview okay so uh
Teddy uh This Record is is taken off
like crazy
what he said all right back to business
hold on get back on the let's get back
on the
road there going to be a remix coming um
you know we we we talked about it we'
chatted about it and I I would like that
you know but also it's with the way that
the record's doing right now um we're
expecting it like we released in June
and we're expecting to probably peak in
around the same time and later and it's
really just still climbing and climbing
and
so I just I I don't know if it's if if
we did if we did like a remix now I
wouldn't want it to like kind of mess up
the yeah I I don't wanted to like split
streams and and mess it up and so I
think we're in we're in the decision if
like maybe if the right person comes
along and we do the right way then maybe
but you know you never cross streams you
never cross streams no not not unless
it's your best friend yeah or you guys
are drunk behind a liquor store
yeah
you don't split the streams you don't
cross the stream
he I'm having a time of my life man
thank you yeah but I I think I think
it's going to be I think it's I think
it's still growing and doing great and
so uh and also it's it's something cool
about my first uh breakthrough to to be
just [__] turn the [__] radio on
oh [__] it's just your boy on there man
and I'm I'm really happy it's it's just
kind of me and I think for that first
the whole first album I I didn't put out
any any features on it cuz on purpose I
feel like it I wanted it to be like
here's my first [__] big statement
and so I wanted to have my I feel like
most like great debut albums at least on
the hip-hop side I'm thinking like nause
mic only had one feature you know like
like you want you want to hear like this
is unapologetically yourself like this
is me love me for me and then if I do
collabs later on down the road that's
cool too but I don't want y'all to come
over here just cuz so and so was on the
S right I I yeah I agree with that and
and I think it's what imperative that I
finally I I think I kind of found where
I'm where I'm you know where I'm
slivering to so nice nice there's
there's a there's a what's the word I'm
looking for like a artistic uh point of
view or something or like I have my own
little perspective thank you my own
little artist perspective I've kind of
figured out I think nice are you um like
CU obviously you're busy running around
doing what you do how often are you just
creating like like let's say this cycle
right now are you still getting in the
studio yeah nonstop man I'm a I'm a I'm
a I'm like I'm I'm hungry I eat just I
just like I have to I have to I have to
keep riding I'm riding riding riding R
especially when we're on the road we
don't get the opportunity often so like
since I've been back I'm just like I'm
I'm in a session and then in an evening
session and I'm trying to turn out as
many options and and songs as I possibly
can CU I just I I got so much [__] that
I want to say right now and and I'm just
so [__] in love with it man I went
home from to Atlanta and we supp I was
supposed to take like kind of a break
and um I end up staying at my Bas his
house for like 3 days and just kind of
sitting and writing recording and
eventually you know him and his
roommates like bro we're like done
writing we're like want to hang out and
party and and I was like well I guess
you guys don't want as bad as I do [__]
so I was like I'm leaving call my buddy
Chris like was like hey can I come over
there and [__] and I I mean I rang in
the New Year [__] still just I just
can't stop it's just it's like also I
think it's like a maybe a hardcore
anxiety thing that I feel like I just
want to this where my feelings get out
and I'd rather much much rather than go
to a bar like a club just be [__]
[__] houseing the house on a microphone
it's just the best if you want to see me
come to the studio you know where I'm
going to be you Pokemon on your hand
yeah man little Bulbasaur oh [__] your
tattoos are [__] they're getting
there man they're what's the most random
tattoo I mean besides Martin Lawrence's
face on your leg um so I I I'll pull it
out for this camera right here it's so
stupid dude I so hey don't pull it out I
not that out I'm well like but you can
pull the tattoo if I would ever get
tattooed it would be more of a hi and
not a hello you know what I'm
saying
so might went over some people's heads
it's okay I'm a grower not a shower baby
yeah that's exactly what I mean to say
I've gotten no complaints thus far and
if it were any bigger You' just be
hurting people you don't want to do that
you got to unell so you can overd
deliver yeah I guess we'll see if that
works but so I got this i got this
tattoo on my back it was like three
years ago now and I haven't finished it
cuz it [__] hurts so bad dude it's
the worst pain ever and
saw this Meme and um you know this meme
of Jesus Crossing up the devil on and it
was all over the place and he like so so
I went to my buddy Derek and I was like
dude this would be hilarious to [__]
get this done and uh here I'll show it
to you it says [__] stupid I haven't
got the devil finish cuz it hurts so bad
oh [__]
[__] that's your whole back I know the
whole [__] thing man so and we added
Jordan Ones on him too which is so
stupid and
like and I got so much work I still got
background to do on it I still got like
oh you got a lot I got another like
eight hours on that and it's [__]
just to just to finish this [__]
stupid ass joke that I thought was
hilarious and it's just not frankly now
I'm committed not as funny anymore and I
don't know what I was thinking dude cuz
if I'm like walking around with my shirt
off at the beach or at the pool then I
know everybody's just laughing behind my
back you know I just made myself a
[__] idiot like to everyone you got
Jordan
Crossing it's so stupid and I I even
think about it too like when I'm like
you know when I'm with my girl and we're
like doing the dirty or whatever there's
no position where she see in my back so
it's like I'm and I'm not like the best
in shaped guy either so my shirt's just
not off often anyway so it's like what
am I what the [__] was I thinking but
you're you're committed now yeah I got
to finish yeah I might go get put
[__] put under the [__] anesthesia
though and just like please numbing
cream yeah this [__] don't [__] back
tattoos [__] man that hurt so bad yeah
my whole back done it sucks God damn uh
so before you go you're from the south
there's been a lot of uh disparaging
comments about In-N-Out Burger from
people from the South when they come to
La they say in-n-out's
overrated let's talk fast food for a sec
okay you guys got Zach be down there
Zach [__] yeah we love raisin canes too
that's good I like raisin canes I get
down on that um I think I think for me
though the the uh uh In-N-Out Burger I
think the burger is is is top-notch I do
love that burger like when I want a
shitty Burger I'm going for that shitty
burger like and that's to me the top
notch fast food Burger yeah I think I
think see that's that's and we can all
agree the the fries are [__] but I
think also too I found out not too long
ago when I got the fries that those are
the only fries on the planet that get
better like two hours after they set out
like they don't they don't get like
shitty like McDonald's fries they
actually kind of get a little bit better
or maybe the and then if you get animal
style yeah maybe maybe the the bar is
just so low that consecutively 3 hours
later still be that shitty like fresh
potatoes they just and then they here
you go they're just they're not they're
not process yeah see maybe that's what's
wrong with them maybe we just [__]
Americans just love just [__] toxic proc
all this process [__] that's I find
when I go to Europe too it's the same
way like when I go get like some fast
food like Taco Bell it's like this
[__] not near as good as I wanted it
to be like in like London or something
you know they Taco B in London yeah oh
wow that's an interesting choice of food
if you're in London well but I I had to
go try it out out you know and and but
it's different cuz it's yeah
everything's got to be real food you
know so like even your McDonald's burger
is 100% beef and it's like I don't want
100% beef I want like cardboard and like
crushed up beetles and
[__] I want give where's the [__]
cardboard and the crushed up beetles you
know what I'm saying where's the little
fiberglass inside of it you know I don't
want my burger to like you know you've
seen those videos of like a there' be
like a McDonald's burger 5 years later
and it looks the same yeah I want that
inide body yeah I want it to sit in my
belly for the next 12 years eternity I
want to be buried the only thing you
could take to grave with you is the
McDonald's burgers you had and your
tattoos everything else you know you
can't you can't take you can't take
nothing else when you go but you can
sure take that [__] McDonald's gut
with you there it is man well look
congratulations on all the success lose
control is going
crazy um thank you man we hardly got to
that at all did we it's all right we got
to run it back again yeah got
congratulations though man it's been
dope to see you know just your whole
I've been following it man so it's good
to it's good to see a a real genuine
person who's just incredibly alien like
talented man I appreciate so much thanks
so much for we got y we'll do it again
and again man anytime there it is man
Teddy swims appreciate you brother boom
can we show some love to our family at
harden man shout out to harden man look
if you're in Vegas you got to pull up
you got to say take me to harden right
now I need to go to harden they're going
to take you they're going to get you
situated hardine Las Vegas the best
cannabis uh dispensary I've ever walked
into in my life the most craziest
selection of Premium cannabis in the
entire world I mean that place smells
like
God's uh sweat it feels it just smells
so good in there it's just oh they got
their own scent they're our family too
man so make sure you follow them online
Hardin Las Vegas all right shoot them a
follow on uh Instagram also go to Hardin
Las vegas.com and when you're in Vegas
make sure you P up to hardine baby